so you gotta hear this I haven't bring
your friend in here robbing the maid of
friend charges 100 bucks friend that's
right you made a friend like I didn't
make her she made a friend charge 100
bucks to rub your feet for she was good
at it I mean I'll give the best I just
you know what if you've gotten your foot
rub by somebody yet probably had a
person who was taught by Laura Norman
well all I know is I could do it as good
as hard and that's the point what
blindfold you you know she wanted to
help you she wanted to send you
information as to what to rub and how to
rub I said don't give him any help I
don't know of course how are you Laura
great I'm so glad to be here with you I
bet
easy Baba Booey I told Robin on the air
the other day I come as good as you are
believe me I can rub her feet just as
good what we're gonna do is Robin what
does she got to wash your feet I don't
you know a little wash your feet it's
true we want to touch your feet yeah an
aromatherapy foot soak oh you know I see
a line of aromatherapy why cause you got
a massage a lot of stinky people's feet
Roman therapy that's for the massage my
feet never smell never I'm a very cool
probably because I have a tremendous
diet diet I've smelled his feet
no you have I have - you have never
smelled my nice I'll take my shows the
shoes off right now maybe today's a good
day yeah so uh Robin will take out her
smelly nubbins she will soak them in
that why don't we take a break
Laurie you can prepare at the same time
so you need me to give each one of you a
foot yeah baby
all right now both of us are rubbing
feet at the same time now Robin a aware
that
[Music]
and I guarantee how are you feeling
Robin Laura how are you doing I'm doing
great I see you're starting to copy me
I'm not don't give hints and don't say
anything
[Music]
anybody can do this how much you charge
for this how much you charge to rub feet
100 for me 75 for an associate that's it
when they come to our office if we go to
the home or hotel or hospital or office
it's double Roberts sweet little nubbins
are being rubbed by you I say I'm very
relaxed notice I'm quiet I'm gonna fall
asleep and then you feel very energized
afterwards you know what I think I think
this should be done during the show all
the time you're on drugs
alright I'm gonna ask both people to
stop now
now Robin I want you to be dead honest
about this foot massage crap all right I
really want you to be honest honestly
now now this foot over here I wouldn't
know what your betters okay who do you
think rub that foot that was Laura's
foot okay and which foot was this one
that was your foot all right you are
completely wrong I told you